[Music]  have you ever been a nanny  this is my first live in chopped well I  hope you know what you're doing the  children are very special Kate they're  thoroughbreds use your friends must love  it here I have no friends you have no  friends yep  well you have one now maybe the parents  died nothing she have to suffer it's not  that simple  I don't I'm not part of the house why  not don't wanna hello  you shouldn't be in here what happened  to your last nanny like I'd tell you  need to take charge Hecate I know what  you're afraid of keeping a light Sun  won't keep you safe can you please stop  yeah I mean there I'm not going anywhere  Thomas Thomas cross my heart nope stop  everyone dies miles did you see anymore  [Music]  stop now  [Applause]  bad dreams  [Music]  you